house minority leader nancy pelosi
catching heat for these comments about
the economy
under president trump i pick hooray
unemployment is down
what does that mean to me in my life i
need a bigger
paycheck this isn't just about the
unemployment rate it's about
raise wages rising in our country
so that consumer confidence is restored
senator bernie sanders also lashing out
against the president
trump campaigned you said you remember
this i
will not cut social security medicare
and medicaid
believe me i'm not paul ryan that's what
he said his budget
trillion dollar cut in medicaid proposal
500 billion dollars in medicare
massive cuts in education nutrition
programs he's going to war
against working people so jesse if new
fox news poll out shows president trump
i think at 44 which it might be
at their highest they've been his it's
he's been in that poll
and the key driver for the president is
handling of the
economy uh there you see it on the
screen i think it was 52 percent
um so what do you make of the fact that
leading democrats pelosi sanders others
are like well what about wages what
about wages one i remember just the
other day you said something about wages
being flat under this presidency i think
it's 0.3
nope that would be 2.9 percent close to
3 and that
is the fastest rise in wage growth since
2009. what are you talking about and
it's
my pleasure to fact-check you yeah yeah
yeah also consumer confidence
0.3 is the last thing i saw wait
and that's a fact so also consumer
confidence it is an
18 year high so i don't know what pelosi
is talking about
when you combine that with oh
whoop-dee-doo the jobless numbers are
down and crumbs
and ms-13 they have a spark of dignity
inside them
those are just made-to-order republican
ads gutfeld was laughing in the break
about it
i mean she could not cut a better ad for
the republicans than she has so far
nancy we love you so kimberly bernie
sanders says this is a
this is a war on working people being
waged by the president who wants to
he said he would never cut medicare
medicaid social security
but in fact his budgets look intent on
doing just that yeah i mean look i think
bernie sanders has been having too many
like cafeteria lunches with nancy pelosi
because both of them seem to be getting
kind of confused but it's
actually their comments are really only
helping to motivate
the president's base and when you look
at the numbers and it just flies in the
face of their illogical
comments and statements when you see an
economy that's booming like this you see
that women
minorities blacks all more engaged in
the economy you see the numbers
in terms of jobs available record low
unemployment
this is something that america wanted
this is why he was elected
and you see here somebody like nancy
pelosi seems completely
out of touch doesn't make any sense one
gaff after the next
if that's the future right of the
democratic party they're in big trouble
going into the midterm elections
and going into 2020. that's the problem
when you look at this right now people
are saying look
this is something that's sustainable in
terms of economic growth
the democrats are out of talking points
but they're not
out of gaffes so dana again going back
to the polling
what you see coming from pelosi is an
argument that
when people don't have wages they can't
afford health care they can't pay the
high cost of prescription drugs
they can't pay for their kids to go to
college are we seeing the evolution here
of the democrats
uh messaging for well i think that this
is consistent across the board it's not
like she's making gaffes
okay they are actually spending money on
ads in their primaries that are saying
the same thing so something is telling
them
either their polling or their focus
groups are telling them that this
message works
for their particular voters and one of
the things about this that the
republicans just need to be a little bit
concerned about is that
the president's numbers are better the
generic ballot is better
but the democrats are highly motivated
to register new voters
i didn't know this until the other day
in the virginia election for the
gubernatorial race last november
more republicans turned out to vote than
in the history of the country
in virginia and still at gillespie lost
by nine points
one of the things that happened is 12 of
the voters in that election
had never voted in a gubernatorial
election before so the democrats are
very good
at figuring out where to go and register
new voters and getting them to the polls
no matter what the economic results are
they can get their people to the polls
more than republicans
then they could actually squeak out a
win in november sounds like voter fraud
amen by the way dana in the fox bowl
now it's it's back to plus nine uh for
for the democrats in terms of
generic preference so you know greg
i was looking at the polls and it's you
know of course people who
like president trump say the economy is
their number one reason for liking
president trump
so i said what what are people because
he's still underwater it's
44 45 approved 51 disapproved so i said
well why would people disapprove
of a president that greg and jesse and
kimberly love so much
so i thought i would have dana and it
says oh dana oh
please sir and the question comes so
number one he doesn't
know what he's doing right the number
one reason that people disapprove number
two he doesn't have the temperament for
the job number three
he's divisive and racist what do you say
i
say that i think you just try to pose a
question that you wanted to express your
own opinions within
look you uh you know you're losing uh
democrats are losing when you're mocking
low unemployment right
last week okay so this week you're
mocking low unemployment
last week you were defending ms-13
what's next
next week nancy what are you going to do
come out in favor of measles
i mean i'm sure when they show her the
california leader the pictures of those
homeless encampments in over under
overpasses in california
she calls them california condos yo this
is a party where stormy is now their
mother teresa
you guys are in trouble it's a big
trouble terrible